[Musique]
fric frac oui mais non pas à fric frac
en chansons comme celui que vous avez vu
lundi l'émission d'aimer partis mr un
fric-frac en paroles en somme puisque
précisément derrière cette porte habite
georges descrières qui a présenté le
fric frac en chansons alors nous voulons
lui dire quelques mots
ça y est
pas mal ici la personne
ah je vous attendais bonjour je vous
asseyez vous alors comme ça vous faites
un fric-frac chez moi et bien somme
toute ont été les spectateurs moi je
vous rend la politesse puisque vous vous
avez fait devant eux un fric-frac alors
précisément à ce propos comment se fait
il que les sociétaires de la comédie
française
hirsch manuel charron et vous et bien
d'autres semblent avoir une sorte de
dents vie de faire ce qu'on appelle des
variétés et bien parce que ça nous plaît
énormément
nous aimons beaucoup les variétés et
ensuite parce que ça nous change du
répertoire classique que nous aimons
beaucoup moi j'aime beaucoup le théâtre
français
mais en sortant deux
jouez pas lieu tout andromaque ou des
pièces assez sérieusement tout temps
vincent par le fil à la patte ou le
dindon il m'est très agréable de
participer à des émissions de variétés
complètement farfelues comme celles que
vous avez vu lundi dernier je remarque
d'ailleurs que les comédiens du
boulevard comme on dit aspirer à l
inverse à faire du classique
oui mais c'est un phénomène de
compensation joe johnson vous avez joué
pratiquement presque tous les rôles du
répertoire comme on dit presque tous
n'ont quand même pas mais enfin bon goût
déjà lequel préférez-vous
mais c'est le dernier en date que j'ai
joué c'est don juan pourquoi parce que
d'abord c'est un rôle merveilleux c'est
le plus beaux rôles du répertoire et
ensuite parce que c'est un rôle qui est
maintenant dans mon emploi
j'aspire maintenant à des roses qu'on
appelle les premiers grands rôles dans
le répertoire classique
est ce que c'est une question si vous
voulez de maturité d'un jean quelque
sorte tout aussi une question morale
je crois que ces deux georges descrières
vous êtes comédiens à la fois au théâtre
au cinéma la télévision à la radio même
pouvez vous être un spectateur et même
un téléspectateur comme les autres
absolument pas je le vends je ne sais
pas si les autres comédiens sont comme
moi mais
moi quand j'ai joué au théâtre je suis
un spectateur et je réagis comme un
spectateur je ne suis pas juge et partie
je reçois et quand la pièce est gay je
ris quand la pièce est triste et
dramatique
je ne pleure pas mais enfin je réagis en
fonction vous êtes bon public très je
crois vous êtes marié à une comédienne
très connu jeune jay brunet que nous ne
verrons malheureusement pas parce que
précisément elle tourne en ce moment en
mayenne et pour la télévision
il vous est arrivé assez souvent de
jouer ensemble et il agréable ou au
contraire plus difficile d'avoir sa
femme pour partenaire oui il est bien il
y a deux choses c'est à la fois plus
agréable et c'est à la fois moins
agréable parce que moins agréable car on
est inquiet pour deux vous savez que
plus on joue plus on a le trac et je me
souviens d'un mot de marguerite moreno
lors d'une interview à la radio on lui
disait mais madame vous jouer d'une
façon absolument détendu grèce que vous
avez peur elle dit oui j'ai peur et j'ai
de plus en plus peur et je crois c'est
une question de responsabilité on est
responsable de ce que l'on fait on
ne veut pas décevoir un public qui vous
a vu apprécié dans certains rôles et
c'est pour ça qu'on a peur alors on
pense à sa femme est elle aussi est dans
le coup exactement exactement pour ça
qu'on a peur pour deux vous avez des
enfants
oui vous avez deux filles l'un et
l'autre
vous jouez beaucoup vous êtes
constamment occupés est ce que vous
pouvez quand même vous occupez
l'éducation de vos enfants
oui et d'ailleurs je veux pas dire que
nous dirigeons notre carrière en
fonction de notre vie familiale mais
nous ne laissons pas de côté ce
ce problème est si bien que il m'est
arrivé
ma femme également maintes et maintes
fois après avoir répété toute la journée
jouant le soir alors que nous étions
fatigués et bien lieu de nous reposer
nous rentrons et nous voyons nos enfants
pour qu'ils nous aient vu dans la
journée pour en profiter vous aussi et
gagner je crois que notre devoir à nous
c'est de vous laisser maintenant à vos
enfants
oui il est l'heure d'ailleurs du
déjeuner et j'entends une de mes filles
qui m'appellent merci beaucoup je vous
en ferai
[Musique]